c'est vrai c'est vrai que j'ai mis un
temps fou à trouver les mots justes pour
ce soir c'est difficile aujourd'hui il
faut bien peser chaque mot choisi
c'est vrai que ça a été un vrai casse
tête chinois
d'ailleurs chinois je passe sur qui file
utiliser ce soir bonsoir
même ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit bien
bonsoir à tous ça c'est peut-être trop
bonsoir à tous et à toutes mais là c'est
un peu con sensuel c'est non je veux
dire bonsoir à tout
bonsoir à tout
depuis des semaines maintenant je reçois
comme florence beaucoup de témoignages
d'empathie d'encouragement un peu comme
si j'allais à l'abattoir mais trêve de
plaisanterie je suis extrêmement
heureuse extrêmement touchée d'être la
présidente de cette très particulière
45e cérémonie des césar la dernière
d'une époque est la première du début
d'une autre cette année a été comme vous
le savez très légère calme sereine très
soft je ne me sens absolument pas
légitime pour dresser la liste de ce qui
pourrait changer les choses mais je
souligne que cette année symbolique de
la parole libérée de ses voix
courageuses qui se sont élevés et qu'ils
feront que nos enfants j'espère ne
suffiront plus jamais l'intolérable
symbolique aussi parce que j'ai été
élevé avec cette phrase qui m'est
devenue si familière et qui est
peut-être familière pour vous aussi
d'ailleurs
derrière un grand homme se cache une
grande femme et je sais que cette année
est symbolique parce que la bataille
continue plus que jamais pour que des
grandes femmes soit aux côtés de grands
hommes et victor hugo le disais il ya
bien longtemps maintenant donc ça date
pas d'hier
une moitié de l'espèce humaine et or de
l'égalité il faut l'y faire rentrer
donné pour contrepoids aux droits de
l'homme le droit de la femme
voir
merci
pour en revenir à ce soir j'aime j'aime
comme vous tous passionnément
profondément le cinéma cette passion
nous lient au plus intime de chacun
d'entre nous l'art le cinéma a toujours
été le meilleur porte parole de
mouvements de changement parfois même le
symbole d'une révolution regardez en 68
le festival de cannes avait servi de
rendez-vous de levier pour faire changer
les choses je pense très fort à jean luc
godard à françois truffaut à claude
lelouch et à maurice pialat et je pense
très fort encore plus fort je dois dire
à mes amis daniel toscan du plantier et
mon amie agnès varda
ce soir ce soir c'est ici que les
artistes ont voulu témoigner d'une
époque révolue
bien sûr ça fait peur c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais je crois profondément aux
vertus de la crise et aux révolutions
qui peuvent pas se faire sans douleur
mais qui sont pour moi je pense vraiment
porteuse d'un grand espoir et j'ai
surtout confiance vraiment confiance
dans la nouvelle génération et dans les
films et tous les films nommés ce soir
alors je vais les cités comme florence
mais raconte notre monde et notre pays
bien mieux que n'importe quel discours
sans vouloir les réduire évidemment et
quelques mots je pense aux misérables
qui traite évidemment de la banlieue et
de nos sociétés très branlante hors
norme la puissance des associations et
les manques de l'état la belle époque le
pouvoir de l'imaginaire roubaix lumière
la misère sociale
j'accuse les ravages de l'antisémitisme
qui fait encore débat aujourd'hui alors
que c'est fou
grâce à dieu la parole libérée la
pédophilie et portraits de la jeune
fille en feu l'impossibilité pour les
femmes de disposer de leur vie d'autres
films encore comme les invisibles comme
tu mérites un amour
comme c'est ça l'amour sont pour moi un
élan nouveau vraiment nouveau de
cinéaste libre qui parlent de nous
écouter voilà nous sommes si privilégiée
de faire du cinéma c'est équipe
solidaire qui forme qui se forme autour
d'un cinéaste d'un regard tendu tous
comme ça vers le même but de raconter
une histoire pour faire rêver ou
peut-être même parfois pour changer un
peu le monde
c'est vrai qu'on peut tout inventé avec
le cinéma jeux j'ai envie d'avoir des
fleurs plein les rues en décembre pape
j'ai des fleurs plein les rues en
décembre c'est magique c'est magique ce
plateau où un étranger à un tournage qui
nous surprendrait nous prendrait pour
des fous c'est vrai le langage d'un film
les codes les codes que nous sommes les
seuls à connaître quand même à
comprendre par ma selle gueuse hscp
athées ou agnostiques et en scène
s'adresse à une actrice à un acteur en
dix ans soit beau et laid à la fois
quand tu ris en pleurant le pays du
cinéma est unique au monde
et c'est mon pays préférés profitons je
vous en supplie profitons de cette
soirée qui nous unit pour fêter le
cinéma
godard l'a dit je ne veux parler que de
pourquoi parler d'autre chose avec le
cinéma on parle de tout on arrive à tous
je déclare avec fierté et émotion la
voix trahit tout ouverte la 45e
cérémonie des césar et musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]